hallo mein name ist luca und wir zeigen
euch heute wieder einen zieht und zwar
wir sind ich und dass das jetzt machen
und damit machen wir jetzt an
ja wir haben heute wieder einen tollen
zieht am start sehr viel was kann sonst
sagen weil den heutigen
wir zeigen den jetzt in süd und zwar
haben wir heute bei dem sie gegen die
mehr als 40 oder mehr als 50 diamanten
die komplett ins panel sind hier hinter
dir hier da wo wir gerade gespannt sind
war hier da vorne sind wir da haben wir
alles kaputt gemacht als wir gerade das
lied gesungen haben hier vorne hatten
wir im dorf das schauen wir gleich auch
noch in die schmiede rein und zettel
steht nun dort hinten wo wir die ersten
jemanden haben richtig okay wir sind
jetzt hier in einer schlucht direkt am
spot- und hier sind schon die ersten die
hat das sind 12 3 4
ja vier diaz dass die sind die
koordinaten 460 10 und 372 da findet ihr
nämlich diese diaz da haben wir schon
mal vier stück und die sind alle direkt
am spoiler sowie habt ihr vom sports
quasi müssen runter bauen herunterfallen
und habt ihr lust habt hier 100 noch so
eine komplette schlucht und was hier
oben noch ist ich einst porno bisschen
ein bisschen scheiße du bist so klug du
brauchst dich links hoch und rechts ist
einfach unser feuerwehr hier vorne sind
wir gerade nach unten gegangen und wenn
wir jetzt beispielsweise einfach mal in
diese richtung fliegen habe ich solche
freund schon gezeigt dass hier ist
einfach so ein übels kleines tor hier
haben wir es gerade runter gebaut da ist
irgendwie so ein kleines scheiß doch
hier das große dorf hier vorne in der
schmiede haben wir keine diamanten drin
aber fünf einen ingo zu jazz plate in
goldingen apple nördlingen pilz so hier
vorne sind wir gerade gesponnen und
jetzt ist apple gerade was funktion ja
herr harry war doch diaz meinte gerade
das jetzt eine stelle kommt mit 19 die
us sports
was noch ein kleines bisschen mehr auf
hier vorne haben wir das dorf was vorhin
ja einfach ist das
ja ja jetzt haltet euer maul
wir haben hier vorne erst mal sonne
offengelegte schlucht quasi und
hey bei uns runter bisschen mehr ich
stehe nicht in ihr kann ich aber auch
auf eine bibel runter wenn du so willst
also dann mache ich hier arbeite ich
komme die augen so schön schwarz wenn
wir uns hier immer weiter runter bauen
sehen wir das hier haben wir zwei jahre
dann haben wir hier 1 2 3 4 5 6
314 so zwang haben wir hier 1 2 dann
haben wir hier 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
14 15 16 17 18 19 19 stück das heißt
schon krass das ist eine distanz von den
blöcken vielleicht 19 diamanten hier das
also bisher sind wir bei 28 diamanten
bei diesem sieht 411 und 190 wenn ihr
uns nicht glaubt dass sie wirklich 19
diamanten so sollen da ist das dorf hier
sind die nächsten diamanten und hier
waren vorhin genannten alles auf einem
fleck das ist direkt neben dem wir uns
einfach untergegangen und wenig zufall
wir haben ja wir haben hier wieder ein
komplettes
okay dann haben wir hier drei quasi dann
haben wir hier noch acht stück das heißt
hier auch wieder elf diamanten dann sind
jetzt insgesamt seien 39
hier vorne haben wir gerade wieder das
tolle dorf wo in der nähe auch das bauen
war und hier irgendwo sind die nächsten
die us ministerin zwar haben wir hier
fünf insgesamt bei 44 dieter hast ja
noch mehr die war dass sein board halb
nachricht ich kündige dass sie sind die
koordinaten 460 12 und 300 und krempel
ist schon wieder an einem nächsten ort
das heißt ich gehe mal eben für ihn
er meinte damit den wie nun bei 50
stellt das sind die koordinaten 410 und
185 und luca hier haben wir auf jeden
fall auch
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
die hammer wehrmacht stück ja wir haben
acht stück ich glaube wir sind jetzt
tatsächlich insgesamt bei 58 oder so ja
ich glaube 58 58 ging wirklich hin in
köln war selber nachsehen normal das ist
alles in der nähe vom sport also wenn
ich nochmals vielleicht ein gegner und
mich beispielsweise damit direkt zum
spot importiere sie mir schon nach vorne
und haben da haben wir uns begraben
unter der erde waren wir gerade da
hinten irgendwie da vorne ist das dorf
wo auch noch mal sachen in der schmiede
sind also können quasi einfach direkt
zum dorf laufen euch da den eisen
brustpanzer erholen und mit den alten
sachen irgendwie spitzhacke machen und
noch bevor die nacht unter geht hier
untergraben und da allein schon
irgendwie 20 diamanten kriegen also es
sind mehr als 50 diamanten direkt ans
von fast 60 ja fast 60 wenn euch da
fehlt ihr gefallen und fehlten während
einer damen- und bar freuen wenn ihr
einen daumen hoch geben würdet wenn
jetzt kennt richtig geiles sieht dann
schreibt uns und in die kommentare dann
machen die eventuell in ein oder zwei
wochen noch mal so eine folge und du
hast wieder ein letztes wort kündigung